[موسيقى]
كتيبه مسلمه يهابها الغرب هم احفاد من
ارهقوا الجيش الروسي قبل اكثر من ثلاثين
عاما لا ينفع معهم سلاح مهما كان مدمرا
مجرد ذكر اسمها يثير الرعب في نفوس الجيش
الاوكراني
متعطشون للدماء ولهم طقوس غريبه قبل دخول
المعارك قوات فاجنر بالنسبه لهم هواه لا
يعرفون الرحمه وكانهم يقولون للجيش
الاوكراني فضائع فاجنر التي تصرخون منها
اليوم سنجعلكم تترحمون عليها غدا هي ذراع
بوتين الحديدي الجديد والسلاح الخفي الذي
قضى به على انقلاب قوات فاجنر من هي كتيبه
احمد التي استدعاها بوتين لانقاذ عرشه وما
هي الطقوس الغريبه التي تقوم بها تلك
الكتيبه قبل دخولها ايام معركه وما هي قصه
الانقلاب الذي حاول الاطاحه ببوتين وبمجرد
للتصادم معها تراجعت على الفور لتعرف
اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه
الغضب الروسي
بوتين يجلس على مكتبه ويامر غاضبا
يستدعوكبه احمد فورا هناك كارثه تحدث الان
لن ينهيها الا تلك الكتيبه اي كارثه اثارت
جنون الدب الروسي انتهت معركه ضخمه في
اوكرانيا يظهر قائد ميليشيات
الذي يلقبه الغرب بطباخ بوتين في مقاطع
مصوره وهو ينهال بالشتائم على الجيش
الروسي وقادته روسيا في موقف سيء فما فعله
اظهر جيشها في وضع انشقاق وكان كتائبه
تتناحر بين بعضها البعض قائد فاجنر يقدم
على كارثه ويعلن انقلابه على بوتين قائلا
لن تقبل قواتنا بالعمل تحت امره وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه مجددا الجيش الروسي قام
بقصف قوات لنا عمدا في مواقع مختلفه ووزير
الدفاع يتعمد حجم السلاح والدعم عنا هي 25
الف مقاتل يمتتلون لاوامري وادعو الشعب
الروسي للانضمام لنا وعصيان قادته سيكون
لروسيا رئيس جديد يا الهي هل جننت يبرد جن
اتدعو لتمرد مسلح ضد بوتين موسكو تشتعل
غضبا ووزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو يرد
قائلا لقد ارتكب خطا فادحا وضع نفسه في
مرمى تهمه ستزج به في السجن لسنوات طويله
وكان شايغو يتوعد قائد فاجنر صاحب الاثنين
عاما بالسجن بقيه حياته ولكن يبدو ان وزير
الدفاع الروسي كان ارحم ببريغوجي كثيرا من
الرئيس الروسي فثور وصول النبا الى بوتين
اعلنها مدويه
ساقصقص قبل ان اذبحه هذا المتهور قد عجل
بنهايته ماذا تنوي ان تفعل يا بوتين
استحضار اشباح القوقاز قالوا في الامثال
لا يفل الحديد الا الحديد وكان العصيان
الذي اعلنه قائد على موسكو كان هو تذكره
دخول شبح جديد الى ارض المعركه شبح اكثر
شراسه وقوه وتعطشا للدماء من قوات فاجنر
هدفه الاول هو محو بريكوجين وميليشياته
التي يتفاخر بها من الوجود شبح سيجعل
جحافل فاقنر تهرب من امامه وبسببه سيترحم
الاوكرانيون على ايام بجنر التي يصرخون
منها الان هذا الشبح هو كتيبه احمد
الشيشاني المتعطشه للدماء فما هي قصه هذه
الكتيبه اسود القوقاز الشرسه اكثر من عشره
الاف مقاتلهم من اشرس واق المقاتلين
المحترفين في العالم هي الكتيبه الاقوالد
الرئيس الشيشاني وحليف بوتين القوي رمضان
قادروف اطلق عليها اسم كتيبه احمد نسبه
لوالده احمد قديروف الرئيس الشيشاني
السابق الذي تم اغتياله عام 2004 رمضان
قادرون يطلق عليه الغرب ابن بوتين المدلل
قام بتاسيس تلك الكتيبه عام 2022 لتامين
نفسه ولدعم الجيش الروسي في حربه ضد
اوكرانيا والغرب نعم كتيبه احمدهم مسلمون
ولكنهم يتميزون بطقوس غريبه قبل خوضهم اي
معركه فهم يكبرون ويصلون صلاه الفتح ثم
يدخلون في ذمار المعركه والغريب انهم
دائما يخرجون من المعركه منتصرين لهم
طريقه بشعه في القتال تبث الرعب في نفوس
اعدائهم لا يتباكون على قتلاهم او جرحاهم
يزيد اصرارهم على قتل اعدائهم عكس
ميليشيات فاجنر التي لطالما اشتكى قائدها
من كثره قتلاهم وحمل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
مسؤوليه ضحايا ميليشيات في الحروب عناصر
كتيبه احمد يلتقطون الصور بجانب ضحاياهم
وهم قتلى يقاتلون في اوكرانيا بجانب
القوات الروسيه تلك هي الكتيبه التي
ارسلها بوتين لمقاتله ميليشيات
ومواجهه تمردهم المسلح وربما لمحو قائدهم
نفسه من الوجود فما هي اخر التطورات
التوجه نحو روسيا تتحرك قوات فاجنر نحو
روسيا وتسبح عكس التيار زعيمهمبر
الروسيه والسيطره عليها وهروب رئيس هيئه
الاركان الروسي
يهاجم وزاره الدفاع ويهدد ليلى الشر الذي
تحمله القياده العسكريه الروسيه ويجب ان
يتوقف دخلنا روستوف وكل المنشات العسكريه
بالمدينه اصبحت تحت سيطرتنا اولئك الذين
قتلوا الالاف من ابناءنا وعشرات الالاف من
الجنود الروس في الحرب في اوكرانيا
سيعاقبون اطلبوا منكم عدم المقاومه اي شخص
يفعل ذلك سيعتبر تهديدا لنا وسيتم تدميره
ينطبق ذلك على اي نقاط تفتيش وطيران على
طريقنا ماذا يحدث في روسيا الدب الروسي
مهدد في عقر داره بوتين يامر بارسال كتيبه
احمد الى مقاطعه رستوف لمواجهه ميليشيات
تصل الى بريغوجين وما حدث كان غير المتوقع
يبدو ان قائد فرقه فاجنر قد شعر بان
الامور لن تسير كما خطط لها وان الانقلاب
على بوتين ليس بالامر السهل بل هو لعب
بالنار فعند اقتراب كتيبه احمد من مقاطعه
رستوف على نايف
تراجع قواته وانه امرهم بالخروج من
المدينه حقنا للدماء بعد ان كانوا على بعد
نحو 200 كيلومتر فقط من موسكو هل كنت تنوي
دخول موسكو بقواتك وما سبب هذا التراجع
المفاجئ يا ترى كلمه السر لوكاشنكو لا
يمكن استبعاد قلق قائد فاجنر العجوز من
كتيبه احمد المتعطشه للدماء خصوصا وانه
يعرف قدرات وشراسه افراد تلك الكتيبه جيدا
وانها رغم قله عددها مقارنه بعدد افراد
فاجنر فانها لن تكون بعيده النصر على
فاجنر والقضاء عليها تماما لذا فظهور سمي
كتيبه احمد في المشهد لابد وانه حمل
تاثيرا على قرار بريغوجين بالتراجع لانها
ستكون معركه لا يتدخل فيها الجيش الروسي
القتال سيكون بين كتيبه احمد وقوات باجنر
لكن كان هناك شيء اخر يحدث في الكواليس
فقد قام رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكيشنكو
بالوساطه بين بوتين لانهاء النزاع قبل ان
يتفاقم
على التراجع وامر قواته بالعوده الى
معسكراتهم صحيح لم تحدث مواجهه مسلحه بين
فاجنر وكتيبه احمد ولكن السؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه الان ماذا لو لم تتراجع فاجنر وحدثت
المواجهه مع كتيبه احمد الشيشاني شراسه
والتعطش للدماء في مواجهه الزياده العدديه
من كان سينتصر وعلى ايه حال انتهت الحرب
قبل ان تبدا ولكن الازمه لم تنتهي فما
فعله لن ينساه بوتين وبالتاكيد سيكون له
رد يليق به وكان الدب الروسي يقول له ليس
لدي وقت لمحاسبتك الان ولكن عندما انتهي
من حرب ضد الغرب سنتحاسب وسيكون حسابك معي
عسيرا عسيرا جدا
[موسيقى]